well thank you for having me here Jared
it's always it's amazing these
conferences you're having is the first
time I've been here but the stuff you've
put together is just tremendous it's so
neat to see people I've never met before
firstly but also see a bunch of people
that I was talking with max that we had
met first in 2007 and in Iowa and use
our but a whole bunch of people
Marc at DC it's just kind of this
community is awesome because it
continues to get bigger and it's just
the same people are also sticking around
it's it's a blast
so again yes my my name is Jeff Ryan
I've written at least a few packages
over the years actually have no idea
where the clickers either yeah so the
first thing is first that every one of
my like forty other talks I've ever
given are all technical this one is not
technical so we are either going to end
under time or over time and I apologize
for that so kind of brief history on me
all right again
Jeff Ryan I kind of think of myself as
principally a developer like I like
writing code I like solving problems and
ID I don't have any training in computer
science I've never taken a computer
science class which probably shocks a
lot of people who use myself where in
industry but it's it seems to work and
for my current role I actually work as a
data scientist quant for Citadel
investments in Chicago which is a very
large hedge fund I'm work on a desk and
been there for five years also as a
shameless plug we are always looking for
super smart data science people
especially buying group so anybody who's
interested there's me and there's also
someone else here who might be
interested in talking to you so hit me
up on that and then the last part is
this artist thing which is funny because
I'm not really an artist not a visual
artist but what I like is that the stuff
that I I think of art as like creating
something that's not been there before
and kind of gets people to either think
or kind of makes a mark somehow
software I'm good at software sort of
good at software so I kind of count that
as art but I also like art but that's
secondary
and then the our finance thing so Jared
pointed out it's a conference but it to
me it's far more than a conference
conference is this manifestation of kind
of a whole bunch of ideas that were
bouncing around I started writing quad
when I was trading myself I needed some
visualization tool and at the time and
are the only way to see to time series
together were to literally take two
windows like x11 windows and drag them
together and try and align them it was
pretty disastrous and then I did try
ggplot which was brand new at the time
so no no no harm to ggplot but he took
so long to draw anything it was surreal
and again this is 12 years ago but I
remember going to get coffee and
watching a little bars print and then
coming back and they were still printing
so I had to buy it
I had to write something just to work so
that's where quantum I was born in my
basement effectively with a co-worker
and and then XTS kind of came out of
that but the conference is like I say it
comes after this need that this that all
I had and it turned out a whole bunch of
other people of Chicago that I ran into
who all also started writing packages
like georgeta beetle and the performance
analytics guys Bryan Petersen Peter Karl
and then Josh Ulrich who is now the
maintainer of my of climate and xes
whose co-author of XTS as well this is
kind of weird group of people that were
all nearby and we kind of got together
and realized that maybe maybe there's
more if we work together so it's not
it's not bad different than the tidy
verse but we just have like a different
a different mindset and we were not
prescriptive per se we collaborate and
argue back and forth then we try and
make things work together and I think we
do a pretty good job but we tried to
build this universe of things this
community and the last part with this
kind of ecosystem which is getting at
there are a bunch of packages within
our finance space that do sort of what
you want and the weird part about
finance if anybody works in finance is
that you really don't care all that much
about making code that lasts when on the
outside I did because there's I just
wanted to be able to use it forever but
most of the time you are I mean you're
fighting against the market and it's
it's a really tough business to win in
so really getting things done and if
they work you never want to touch them
again so there'll be a part of the stock
that touches on that but but we just
need stuff that worked so that's that's
it and the success thing is kind of
goofy so again its first time I've ever
get in this talk but success to me is
not like some sort of monetary success
or anything like that it's that this
stuff seems to have gotten kind of a
life of its own and continues to get
bigger and obviously this is giant but
like the auto finance space is gotten
giant we're now in our tenth year of the
conference we have 300 people capped
other day I will also point out that I
don't come to New York very often but
it's remarkable how many people you guys
can squeeze in little rooms the so okay
I'll move on to success is kind of this
bigger picture thing okay I've got like
four pieces of this talk and they kind
of are broken down like motivation kind
of responsibility a community component
and kind of a marketing component all
right those are my MBA words I don't
have an MBA and I but I do think their
MBAs are good if Jared Jared I think
attest to that yeah okay so first thing
you are not alone I live in the city I
am told these are stars that you can see
but so but it's a big world and even
though you're just one person it's
probably it's probably more than you the
first bullet here is kind of funny
because at our very first conference in
the in
Chicago we had there was this our metric
suite of tools that was written by this
awesome guy who passed away two years
ago but he was called our met our
metrics and he built this incredible
suite of software that was basically
pegged off of s pluses fin metrics so if
but he wanted to be able to teach his
students with X plus but couldn't afford
it for all the students and so we
decided because R was coming about he
decided to make a version like a clone
of s plus fin metrics in R and but he
came to the conference he and he was
like I idolized him mentor I convinced
him to come to Chicago and he gets on
stage and you know expect a great talk
and gave a great talk but at one point
he just kind of he stopped and he's just
like he's like I write software for me
not you and it was like okay that was
great but is his point was he's writing
for his own purpose like he really
wanted to make the software work for him
it was not to be he didn't care about
sharing and he cared about sharing if it
was only really because he needed his
students to use it and he liked that
other people got to use it too and he
built brilliant software and just a
great guy but but the point of that is I
used the software and I was not a
professor nor one of his students or a
student in student finance but didn't
use it in finance so it turned out there
are a lot more people using his stuff
than he ever dreamed of like he didn't
even care that we were using it which is
kind of what motivated the group in
Chicago to build additional tools
because he was very much focused on
teaching whereas we were focused on the
practical side that we really need the
things to work we needed him to be fast
and it's kind of a different mandate but
so yeah I guess the the last or the
middle to there that kind of your your
first user oh I have one here your your
first user and you are your most
important user so don't don't let other
people's kind of opinions or directions
influence you it's another thing to tell
them told me when I went out to
Switzerland with them and
kind of nicely took me on a boat ride
and walked around he was kind of and I
had built a package that was competing
directly with his and so he could have
tried to sink me on the boat but he he
instead said don't let anybody tell you
to not do this he's like this is
something you've made and stick with it
and if you believe in it just do it so
and this is XDS which ended up actually
kind of crushing his software which he
was fully onboard with like he didn't he
didn't care because again there's not
what he he cared about it hurt me
actually because I really liked the
stuff but that xes thing is funny cuz
right this also goes against a lot of my
talk you'll notice some internal
inconsistencies that's actually just me
but the time series thing so when I
wrote the time series classic came out
of quantum odd and the reason it came
out of want mod was I needed a way for
other people who used all these other
time series classes like TS mts all the
stuff in base our IR TSI TS FTS
resilient of these things and all of
them did something slightly different
and a lot of them didn't follow our
convention so they all kind of bothered
me a tiny bit but none of them were very
fast and then xue came in adams who was
great so everyone uses Umezu didn't have
time she would just ordered observations
alice's ordered observations which I now
co-author of or contributor to put his
funny of the time because like it just
it didn't solve my problem because I
needed to know it was a time series
object coming in so I needed to be able
to test it and write all this stuff so I
decided this XTS class would be able to
take anything you throw at it turn it
into this internal object that I could
deal with and then plot them and do
whatever and then give you back
magically the one that you gave it at
the beginning so like it didn't impact
your workflow at all okay I work with a
IRT s object make up a pretty plot comes
out as an IRT object and nobody's the
wiser what happens inside so the idea
was other packages could you use this
internally to make a bigger user base
better software and that was actually
what happened kind of amazingly again I
surprised myself here a lot to the this
thing is my friend Adam who's I think
hiding down a pole over there is that
pointed this out it's it's this it
happens to be lifted from Wikipedia but
it says Chesterton's fence thing which
is uh I guess
fairly well-known text bakers spaces but
again I told you before I'm not a tech
person per se but basically it's like
you there's weird vents in the middle of
nowhere but it is just because you don't
see a reason for something being there
or being the way it is doesn't mean
there isn't a reason so and the idea
that I take from that is to just sort of
pay attention and really look back and
see what's been done before and be
careful not to rat what's been done
before
so it's I do believe if you're
publishing something you really need to
be responsible for what was there and
pay attention to API calls pay attention
to arguments pay attention to syntax is
abusive as our syntax might be and like
camelcase and dots and all that other
stuff it's like kind of the way R is
it's got to a million users just like
that I'm not thinking I'm good enough to
break it so morally or morally
more to the point is I I kind of needed
to solve or I wanted to solve and what I
think everyone probably also unsolved is
this like what's missing what what do
you need extra but don't mess with the
stuff that's there do the least possible
and that's a because I'm lazy but also
because you do the least amount of
damage if you're only touching a tiny
bit of stuff and the last three here are
there they repeat because they're so
important to me is that no one should
have to learn how to use your software
so Zoo inherited from TS TS was an order
is a is a regular time series and
irregular time series is kind of the
norm and the rest of the world unless
you're doing with like econ data and I'm
act at a macro level so we needed an
irregular time series ooh solve that but
su solved it in such a way that it
preserved the way you constructed things
almost exactly even if the arguments
were named in silly ways that was just
the right way to do it so so you didn't
have to learn a new way or very very
little stuff you had to learn and then
xes subclassed
Zoo to do the same exact thing and then
in the knee part is like I got to then
put the stuff back into Zoo to try and
make everything better and
do even less damage I guess my side it's
not perfect there are many things people
can call me out on that I screwed up
many many things but that's kind of the
motivation this is also not a great
picture but I think this is the Second
Continental Congress but the and it's
also unattributed because there is no
attribution to it the idea here is like
I don't I don't want to tell anyone what
to do I just and I also don't want to
build anything so I don't like writing
code so one of the things was like get
as much that I needed to solve solve by
myself and try and get everyone else to
operate within the same constraints or
bounds and for that to work I kind of
broke it down where it's it's like the
UNIX way it's and I think and as much
the charity says I'm not on board at ID
verse I think and I'm not but but the
the the fitting together the stickers
are super cute by the way but the pieces
little pieces is great like that is what
you want and that is it's awesome
because then you get like the takeaway
there is you get contributors who
otherwise would have to go through this
horrible channel of pushing or you know
asking you sending you a dip in the old
days and I don't like managing that so
the fact that you build something
somebody can use it there somebody
contributed something else is great and
that is I think tiny verse does that
knocks it out of the park
and again the stickers are awesome the
two the two next ones I actually
couldn't again resolve myself to come up
with a simple solution er but you
definitely want to minimize dependencies
I certainly on core packages so like XDS
tries to be as minimally invasive it
only requires zoo because its subclasses
you it relies on zoo for a lot of the
methods that it uses it just does the
one thing ICS does that is different
kind of is it requires your index to be
time where zoo could be anything it
could be the names of animals and they
just happen to be ordered by whatever
you want and they could be
any water he wants and it'll always work
you can merge them together like at
times a cat you've nicked the cat answer
the cat product but it is it's not a
time series so I needed a time series
but it only takes in zoo nothing else
the second part of that is obviously if
you want people to use it you need
reverse dependencies so I encourage
people to use it but also not like I
tried to do as least harm as possible at
the core level so when somebody is using
it they're not seeing five million
packages roll into the screen and
clobbering each other and all of that
stuff which turns out to be horrible and
it's even worse when you're doing
something in production like data
exploration is fine you can swear all
you want for that but when you've got
something running for two years and
generating signal and you're trading on
something and it may be not an R but in
any kind of language you don't want to
go I don't ever want to go back and fix
it and if something else a new version
of whatever XDS came out and broke
something
that can't happen like that it just
can't happen so try and minimize
dependencies and then yeah this the
community thing goes back to the English
system it's like you just want more
people on board so be able to build a
nice place to hang out effectively and
you'll get contributors so and all the
last part I feel like the super ahead of
schedule the last part is is to be
helpful I thought this was funny I was
actually gonna make a QR code myself but
so and the be helpful is super super
duper easy users really matter even if
you're not building something that you
expect other people to use kind of like
detail them but but they do matter
people are great contributors whether in
you know highlighting that just screwed
something up on the documentation or
that you've actually implemented it
incorrectly but they are they are great
and you always need to be respectful of
them because they're you effectively
back to that first picture with the
stars like there are a lot of people
just like you it's basically you
complaining and you just don't have the
bandwidth to do all the complaining so
you have rely on other people to
complain but it works out really well
I like the idea to stay focused on one
thing so I kind of do the time series
stuff at this point but I don't want to
go too far you know out there with
something new though I will say since I
have an audience there's an EM map
package that I wrote that it's awesome
it does is basically like it does with
ffs and big memory do a twitch Dave
gains somewhere around here but it's
very very low level it's vague if you
know C code or if you know anything
about M map it lets you do this but
again in like the least invasive way
possible so you can use it and not have
all these crazy dependencies it doesn't
it doesn't do anything except for make
your life easier I think but try it out
yell at me if it doesn't work and then
documentation I will stress
documentation I like handwritten
documentation I love the fact that are
made this process where you get this
horrible stubbed out Rd file and you
have to go back in and manually fix it
because it it makes you think about it
or at least makes me think about what I
want to convey and conveying it gets you
again more users more people using it
correctly and then more contributors and
more users and more contributors and
then people showing up to conferences
it's it just becomes this cool crowd
that you get to hang out with every year
or twice a year you run into them
randomly in different places and it's
probably not all about documentation but
it gets people on board it helps build
this like successful whatever that is
and the next point is is users are
really important but they also have
their own agenda and they don't own your
project so don't don't really cater to
them like you can you could take
guidance but not all their suggestions
are great 37signals I don't know if
anybody knows Basecamp put they're out
of Chicago but they're a very big
project management firm but they're not
big they're like 30 people and the guys
who run it are fantastic but they they
really have always stressed building
small anyway I'll leave but that is
really it's really you know be humble
talk a lot bad stuff maybe over time and
and just have fun make the stuff you
like have fun with it and try and
broadcast it and get more people on
board I guess it
[Applause]
you